[Music]
homie look what I become
okay so today's podcast will be about
whether uh the population growing is an
issue or underpopulation like a lot of
people are sitting there saying well you
know this whole concept about the way
the population has grown is a very big
concern there are some data that we're
saying that by 2000 by 2100 we will
Flatline and the population will no
longer grow and there are some people
that are wondering whether India is
going to pass up China we have a lot of
different things to talk about we have
the right person in-house second time
with us on the podcast Marion chupi who
has got a new book called Super
abundance he's got very interesting
ideas and thoughts and a lot of good
research here uh born in check uh grew
up in South Africa went to school in UK
and today he's in DC and he's a die-hard
LeBron James fan which will maybe talk
about later on today that was a joke the
last part it's good to have you on man
how you doing thank you I'm delighted to
be with you we are as well man we're
excited to have you here uh so so look
when I think about here senior policy
analysts Center for Global liberty and
prosperity Cato Institute editor
humanprogress.org and then you turn on
the news right now which hopefully will
get into some of these stories
what we saw happen this week this has
been a very weird week by the way like
to say the least what happened with the
trains in Palestine Ohio let's just make
that the basis Palestine Ohio what
happened with the trains in South
Carolina and now yesterday I believe
Houston Houston then you have the the
starlink seeing the things that it saw
over Japan you know then you have the
the balloons the first one that they
took their time and then the second one
second balloon the third balloon matter
of fact I think the fifth one made it
here right no matter where you go
they're not joking like it's just I
and nobody it's getting annoying but
nobody is I don't even think they're not
balloons at this point at this point
listen the way they're shooting it down
they're probably going to be yeah
they're gonna hit it with a burner gun
that would have been sick so anyways but
go going to you
um you know your your background uh your
background what you've done if you don't
mind taking 30 seconds sharing with the
audience your background and then let's
get into your ideas of why you think we
shouldn't be concerned with the
population growing the way that it is
I I think that it all started with
growing up in the communism
absolutely so growing up on the
communism then coming to the capitalist
West and realizing that uh
um you know uh different regimes and
different countries have different sets
of uh political and economic
arrangements and so I was always
interested in what makes countries rich
and what makes countries poor and then
uh given I only have 30 seconds what
happened then was that I realized that
there's this new growing green religion
uh which talks about human beings as
being you know basically a cancer on the
planet and I believe in the exact
opposite I think that the more people we
have provided that they are free so they
can exercise their their minds their
thinking can invest in the market
benefit from it profit from it that
actually having more people in the world
is better because we create more
economic growth and more prosperity for
everyone I that's interesting you're
saying that so I know I said 30 seconds
I want you to feel more comfortable
going because it is a long-form podcast
but you know so for me being where I
grew up and where I'm at now it's very
important for us to know you know like
it was always wanting to find out how
does one become rich can everybody
become rich what are the principles that
help somebody become rich so for you
coming from the check background when I
lived in Germany there was a lot of
folks from Czechoslovakia in 89 that
were escaping you know a family that was
very close to me the staff family Yan
and Katarina specifically family that I
remember you know and they would tell me
stories about what it was like there so
for you what does it what what
conditions and climate helps people
become rich and the same as help some
people become poor
well
everybody not everybody can become
wealthy know everybody can become
successful
um you know you you can only work with
whatever god-given talents uh Slash DNA
uh you have but the first prerequisite
for having at least a shot at being
successful and Rich that is you have to
live in a country uh where uh you have
basically the freedom of both political
and economic freedom uh what do I mean
by political or well freedom of speech
for example is incredibly important uh
to be able to interact with people like
you exchanging ideas learning from each
other
um maybe innovating something together
then applying those ideas in the
marketplace and if it works then of
course profiting now that only works
under some form of a free market system
if you are in North Korea it doesn't
really matter what great ideas you have
you cannot Implement them first you
cannot vocal them because you have a
complete ban on Free Speech but also you
cannot really Implement them in practice
there is no Market where you can succeed
with your ideas or your your Innovations
so I would say that free market over
time has proven to be the the best way
in order to generate economic growth and
it's not just capitalism in the way that
we understand it over the last 300 years
but even if you look at the past it's
it's its localities that have allowed
for greater openness where the
government took its boot off the necks
of ordinary people where where uh where
people were able to flourish and become
rich that includes song China in 12th
Century A.D an incredibly
sophisticated and Wealthy societies and
then when the Ming come in basically
they have 800 years of stagnation simply
because the government changes and they
change the political and economic ideas
institutions that they have uh similarly
in uh you know say for example in in
ancient Rome second century a very high
high level of of stability which then
gets replaced by obviously the collapse
of the Roman Empire in Dark Ages so you
can have these fluorescences of of
economic growth but they usually they
usually Peter out because politics
change and whatever and my big concern
about the United States right now is
that I would like us not to be one of
those uh one of those countries where we
have a sort of a 200 year period of high
economic growth and then suddenly
everything stops and we have stagnation
for the next 500 years by the way if you
look at Stats which countries have grown
the fastest over the last I'm sure
there's data on this the last 50 years I
know India's slowed down ever since they
came up with their one child policy no
China I'm sorry China China slowed down
India keeps making babies the average
age right now in China is 38.4 I think
we're 36.4 I think India's 26 or 27
years old they're very young and they're
if they haven't already he passed up
China in population they're about to but
what what could what countries are you
seeing where the level of population
growing exponentially is a matching
Innovation and which ones are you seeing
that where the population grows
Innovation is declining what what what
trends are you noticing well I would say
that economic growth is really a
combination of population and freedom so
you don't have to have a growing
population uh necessarily if you are
compensating for it with higher degree
of economic freedom so China starts to
liberalize after 1978 and they have a
very high economic growth rate in fact
they are the most successful economy
over the last say four what the 58 or
1978 China sort of drops hardcore
communism I mean it takes time for them
to liberalize in more areas but but the
point is that during the 1980s and the
1990s for the last 40 years China has
been growing quite rapidly even though
they did have the the one child policy
now my argument would be that if they
didn't have the one child policy they
would be growing even faster
India also has succeeded a great deal
partly because they started liberalizing
they started having a more capitalist
system after 1991 reforms and India has
never implemented the kinds of draconian
anti-population policies that China has
so those are two success stories Ireland
is another success story the the the
great disappointment over the last 30
years at least must be Japan uh Japan
which which has basically stagnated but
also many countries in Western Europe
Italy hasn't seen growth in the last 20
years
um and and places like that how has
Italy not seen growth there are some of
the most attractive people in the world
they should be making babies left and
right look I would assume like when
you're like Italian Stallion you're
thinking Sly all these Attractive people
for them to have that kind of emotional
control Vinnie it's got to be patriotic
it's not right so just okay data I just
sent you pull up the data I just sent
you the link I just sent you where it
shows countries whose popular relation
has grown the most can you go up so we
can have actually the leader's bulletin
I don't know if the link I just sent you
shows me a Leader's bullet and do you
see actually the map is quite telling uh
if you look at a map you see that Africa
is the darkest uh has the darkest view
of the of the call on the map and that's
because
um Africa is still growing in fact
Africa is the sub-Saharan Africa is the
only region in the world where women
have more babies than necessary for
replacement level replacement level is
2.1 children per woman per Lifetime and
pretty much everywhere else in the world
can you explain that 2.1 children per
woman per lifetime that's the
replacement level if you want to keep
populations stable you need on average
2.1 children per woman we spoke about
that last yeah and uh and as as you can
see pretty much nowhere else in the
world
um do you have a growing population
except in sub-Saharan Africa so the
question there is why is sub-Saharan
Africa even in spite of its growing
population not generating a lot of
economic growth and the answer is
because they are generally not free if
you grow up in the slums of of uh get a
little closer yeah yeah if you grow up
in the slums of Lagos for example uh you
could be a genius kid but there is
simply very little uh that you can do
with your life um you're probably going
to get a crappy education you're
probably never going to be able to go to
university or Implement your ideas in
the marketplace because you don't have
the capital or whatever so once again I
emphasize that that growth economic
growth Prosperity is an outcome of
population times Freedom so so so is
there any correlation between
um
lack of technology so which country make
like if I look at this uh statistics
from 2012 to 2021 you see what countries
have grown their population the most
okay uh Iraq very interesting not sure
why 37 okay golden lore golden lore
uh Chad Somalia bennin Maldives Uganda
33 Kuwait 27 Afghanistan why are they
increasing at the levels that they're
increasing Qatar a lot of these are
Muslim nations Saudi Arabia Pakistan uh
Israel 18.37 Philippines 17 Iran 16
population growth from 2012 to 2021 on
them grown the most turkey by the way
again a lot of these are Muslim nations
keep going keep going keep going to see
where we go where okay India 11.2
percent Canada 10.7 Costa Rica 994
Switzerland 8.84 Ireland uh right there
uh Mexico eight percent Norway's pretty
much eight percent Brazil seven and a
half percent u.s's population has grown
5.74 since 2012 we're ahead of UK but
keep going I'm trying to see if anybody
okay China's 4.3 they're they're seeming
to have a net negative population in
2022 some of the numbers that I saw
people that are fleeing and leaving
Spain okay now we have negative which
you were talking about Italy minus 0.72
in the last 10 years Japan minus 1.53
uh Armenia 3.23
Ukraine Greece Ukraine is down four
percent Romania is down five percent
keep going keep going keep going
Croatia's down nine percent
Puerto Rico's down 10 percent
uh and then you have at the bottom
Marshall lines okay Puerto Rico Saint
Martin so so when you look at this court
is there anything that says why Muslim
nations are growing faster than others
is there anything we know about that or
no I actually don't know well it's in
the religion in the Quran that got
Muhammad said for them to Spread spread
out as much as they can because their
average I think is three kids but the
majority of the Muslims that we see are
like four or five kids but it's a it's a
it's a it's a religious thing where in
the Quran it says to be flourish and you
know as many kids as you so okay so so
let's let's kind of see if we can come
up with something so one to me you just
said is religion 100 it's in the Quran
so 100 what religion as what can we put
culture as because even Mormonism right
yeah you know the moment you have five
kids people ask you if you're Mormon 100
at four they think they're still maybe
you might be a Christian yeah
we're from uh Bountiful Utah yeah so
religion we have culture uh uh do you
notice that the less there is technology
advancement distractions more babies are
being born
is there a correlation between that like
you know how back in the days people say
well we had 11 kids but because we had
no TV yeah there's certainly a
correlation between
um being a rich country uh and and uh
having fewer babies partly because most
rich countries also have a very high
percentage of women who are in uh
who are in the uh you don't know who are
in the work Workforce
um and um you know staying at home
taking care of children has a much
higher opportunity cost than going and
work in in the marketplace so let's say
that a woman becomes a banker and can
bring in quarter of a million or half a
million dollars a year home uh staying
at home
basically and taking care of children
means that the cost is between quarter
of a million and a half a million right
whereas if you are a woman say for
example in in an African village and you
are not really a part of the official
Workforce but you still work obviously I
mean you work you work at home your
Homemaker whatever but you're not
actually bringing bringing in any
monetary income then then the household
is not suffering that kind of
opportunity cost you know what else I'd
want to know I'd want to also know which
countries in the world lead an abortion
is there a way to pull up this data
pretty sure it's gonna be with which
countries in the world lead in abortion
like what are abortion laws in if we can
just pull up
leading what is the attacking country
the highest abortion rates annual per
thousand woman so yeah at the top is
Russia Russia wow interesting 53.7 out
of uh but that's all four that's all a
lot has happened since 2011. even even
though it's 2004 look at the Stark
difference between one and two oh yeah
no ridiculous can you scroll in on that
a little bit Vietnam and Russia you know
it's not even close
I want to know who has the least I
guarantee you it's going to be a left
hand I bet you Mexico is going to be the
number one that doesn't go to the bottom
let's see if the bottom shows are the
opposite ten count Mexico Mexicans are
not having abortions bro they're just
like no we're good that's pretty wild
that's dope 0.1 like I told your
expertise is AI and abortion
so then he's moving to Mexico yeah yeah
thank you
can we get into these numbers a little
bit yeah where were you going with this
with the with the abortion I'm trying to
see the the areas that are growing with
more kids so his argument was was that
women higher education they not only
don't want to have more kids they can't
have more kids if you're a career if you
want to make your career a priority over
maybe other places where you're working
but you're working for different reasons
to
hear it's more to want to compete so
women is one what else would be the
reason for some of these countries
population to be grown as fast as they
are and some that are not but go ahead
you seem to have a question
well uh
the Russia thing that just throws me for
a loop here I didn't want to go down the
abortion alley over here but that very
interesting how much Russia is leading
the world in abortion do you have any
reason for that you know all of these
things
um you know whether countries are
growing whether they are not whether the
population is declining how many
abortions they have they can have many
different causes
um and and I don't think that we quite
know exactly how they all interact with
each other but Russia is a country which
has had a problem with uh basically
having a very negative view of the
future this has been a case since really
the 1970s China of China Russians have
been suffering from the problem of
alcoholism for a very long time
dying early so there's a lot of stuff
with depression and basically not seeing
Russia as a place that is going anywhere
now one possibility is that you are not
having children partly because of
economic uncertainties but also partly
because uh life generally is is tough
and and and uh and a lot of Russians
just don't see a future for for that
country as opposed to for example Israel
Israel
um the the interesting thing about
Israel is that is that it is a wealthy
country but uh women even though they
are highly educated and they are working
um still keep on having children above
the replacement level and that's not
just the Orthodox Jews but also secular
Jews and one possible explanation that
I've come across is that because Israel
has been growing so fast and and has had
such a positive attitude about its
future for the last 20 or 30 years that
people feel yeah I can I can have a
third baby because the likelihood is
that my income in 10 years time is going
to be much higher than it is right now
now that is not the kind of calculation
that you can make in Russia or in Italy
for that matter interesting well in
Israel I would assume that has a lot to
do with tradition culture economic
freedom
um being free you know there's the book
uh startup Nation uh about the the
miracle that is the the state of Israel
um essentially it leads to your point
right there yeah I mean Patrick has
already written down that you know it's
uh
um you know that there are cultural
aspects to this and religious aspects to
it
um so for the Orthodox Jews it's obvious
why they want to have yeah they're
competing with our friends the Mormons
right oh he might be winning but but
culture the general perception of how
the country is doing and where its
heading can have I think an impact on
how many speaking of you know what we
what you alluded to with Russia or the
this Outlook of negativity like looking
into the future and not being able to
see yourself having a good life I I
actually want to hone in on what's going
on in America today because as you're
saying these stats right
um you know it comes down to political
and economic and socioeconomic and you
see these numbers Rob I slacked you
something if you could the the amount or
the share of generation who is proud
to be American is
falling off a cliff it's actually insane
and it's something that I actually feel
very deeply about if you look here the
net shares of each generation who say
they are proud to live the United States
Baby Boomers who are essentially our
parents you know in their 60s 70s 73 are
proud to live in the United States Gen X
who are in their 40s and 50s 54 and then
it reaches the below the 50 threshold
when you get to Millennials 36 percent
and gen Z
16 you're talking teenagers and 20
something year olds who are abundantly
not proud to live in the United States
and as you're saying these stories about
all right economic freedom check okay
say whatever you want for the most part
check I'm wondering where did this shame
come from based on your findings why
people and young people in America are
not proud to be American this is some of
the deeply deeply bothers me
so once again I think there are probably
a lot of causes at play
um so I want to talk about one or two of
them but before I do that just just get
let's get the numbers right so right now
native born American women have about
1.7 children per woman per Lifetime and
again you need two points 2.1 to replace
yourself okay so so it's mostly
immigration which is still driving
um uh our uh our population forward so
America is still growing in terms of
um in terms of its population we are not
shrinking like the Japanese for example
but it's mostly driven by non-native
American women who are having more
children than immigrants immigrants now
um possibly I I think
one of the reasons that I that is sort
of a
in my mind is that I do meet a lot of
young people and part of the reason why
they feel so bad about America is
because they're actually deeply ignorant
about the rest of the world there is
very little understanding amongst the
young about just how rich Americans are
vis-a-vis the rest of the world now I I
understand that income is not the only
thing which matters but still in spite
of all of our problems 9 11 financial
crisis uh covet Etc
we are the richest generation in the
whole history of the United States we
are much richer than our ancestors were
and not just that Americans are much
richer relative to the second most
developed part of the world which is
Western Europe
um even middle-income America I mean if
if if
if the Western European income
if you compare it to the American states
the 50 states it would be on par with
Louisiana and Mississippi the poorest
states in the union those are the
average income how do you calculate that
what's the what's your what formula did
they use to define a
I think this would be this would be GDP
per capita okay um as far as I recall I
mean I saw it online a number of times
from reputable sources I think one of
them was Timber which is a Swedish
Swedish Think Tank
um and and
the reality is that here in the United
States Mississippi and Louisiana are the
poorest states in the Union
and if you go to the richest they are
roughly twice as rich as the poorest
states in the union California New York
California New York and and Western
Europe is on the level of America's
poorer State
again so let's go back so what causes
people to keep having kids will cause us
people to stop having kids so aside from
a law mandated by the government like
China let's set that aside that's a law
we can't do nothing about a law right
this is depressing to look at this it's
very disappointing to see how gen Z
feels about uh their what do you call it
how patriotic they are but I'm not
surprised gen Z spends the most time
with uh teachers and by the way your
meditate the craziest data about
teachers I'll tell you the craziest data
about teachers here we just got the
statistic this last week based on the
research we were doing with Kai
um do you know what percent and this is
they got this data exactly on how people
gave money contributed towards their
political party what percentage of
Hollywood do you think votes Democrat
it's exactly 90 10. what percentage of
professors
in universities are Democrat to
Republican 90 90 Democrats I would say
more than every one conservative how
many Democrats are there thirteen twelve
twelve it's one of twelve it used to be
it's 1 to 12 1 to 13. there's about 94
exactly so 1-12 is uh uh that's a
full-on monopoly all these people are
worried about there's no bigger Monopoly
than this one yeah but watch this one
here so when you think about gen Z who
do they spend the most time with English
teachers what percentage of English
teachers are Democrats English teachers
in K-12 99 97 yes what percentage of
Health teachers are Democrats Health
teachers in school health and guidance
I'm gonna say 95 99 they're the highest
English teachers are 97 health is 99
here's a little one that they have a
little bit of Reason science and math
what percentage are Democrats remember
this requires logic I'll say 50 87 to 13
okay so 97 is uh English 90 9 is Health
87 is Math and Science and gen z's are
spending time around them non-stop hence
you're going to be thinking like they do
so I am not surprised at all they're
being convinced that America sucks and
America's bad and America is this and uh
get a little one of the benefits about
having YouTube and access to different
channels where you can kind of brainwash
yourself out of the insanity stuff
you've learned you almost need to
unlearn the crap that they've learned
but let me go back this is what I'm
interested in this is what I'm
interested in
so to me what I'm looking for is
formulas okay
what is the formula for happy marriage
are you married are you married okay but
let's just kind of talk about it we'll
open like you know right what do you
what have we heard what is the formula
for happy marriage uh don't lie to each
other be honest with each other respect
respect each other okay so women want to
be loved men want to be respected yeah
so don't publicly humiliate your husband
yeah have a good job be successful you
know don't don't so finances is another
one where there's not a lot of financial
issues faithful faithful which is you're
being faithful to each other each other
maybe there is Faith involved you're
going to some you're practicing some
kind of uh whatever church or
denomination you have what else would
you say is the cause of a long-lasting
marriage effective communication
effective communication maybe common
values and principles the children maybe
you're having sex at least once a week
and I know this statistic I'm interested
in statistics yeah you know what I just
launched in PHP two years ago a couple
came up to me we were sitting down
having a meeting together and I noticed
a trend with a few couples who had been
married for this was couples that were
married for 10 plus years
so many people started telling me that
they don't have sex but once a month and
I said that's that doesn't make any
sense to me in our business we have
something called a perfect week a
perfect week is when that week you make
a certain number of calls a certain
number of prospects a certain number of
appointments a certain number of sales
you do in a week the new perfect week I
added is a date night at least once a
week and you have sex at least once a
week we've added this I said treat your
marriage as a perfect week one date
night sex at least once a week you'd be
amazed how many people Sunday night at
11 59 are getting it on like babe we got
to get our perfect week
that are essential but
but the reason but the reason why I'm
asking this as funny as this sounds and
as like ludicrous this sounds
this is based on a lot of conversations
you have with people and if you're not
having sex in marriage for more than a
month something's going on in that
marriage someone's not happy okay all
right so you go to you know success
formulas for me having a million dollars
in my bank account I don't know set
aside 300 a month at 12 over 30 years or
40 years you're gonna have a million
bucks okay you know what else you do a
thousand dollars a month at 12 over 21
years you got a million bucks in your
account right if you can set us at a
thousand dollars a month at 12 there are
formulas how do you get a raise at a
company how do you keep increasing your
salary how do you stay in shape
I want to know what formulas causes
people to stop having kids and for
people to have more kids more kids lack
of education does that equal more kids
lack of
um you know entertainment and
advancement and technology is that what
causes more kids is it cultural
expectation of hey in our community in
our religion you can have as many kids
as you want five six seven eight kids
what is it okay and then like the the
number that we have that's 2.1 I like
that because we have a number to go off
of that were at least grown our
population I'm more interested to see
what trends do we notice with some
countries that are growing and declining
what is it why is that happening I
really I really do think in the Muslim
nations in the Quran it does say
children are a gift from God and they
just and I know Muslim guys that have I
know a guy one of my boys has five kids
and their attitude is just flood the
world as much as us as we can so so
we'll be we'll be a voice to be heard
and I mean dude it's I mean it's
happening the majority of Muslim men
that I know have at least three kids at
least average and the same I believe in
Judaism the the insistence that children
are a blessing now so I don't have the
formula what I can tell you and what we
address in the book is that
in the west we are embracing the
anti-formula not that children are a
blessing
from God higher power whatever but the
children are a curse upon the world that
humanity is a cancer upon the world that
to bring a child into the world is an
act of ultimate selfishness let's say
that you are young and impressionable uh
young person uh reading the New York
Times Washington Post or the Atlantic
what are the stories that you would have
encountered over the last six months
um having children is selfish children
will consume or will produce more CO2
into the atmosphere in general lifetime
than five trucks or whatever
um and and what we found was that
actually public opinion polls are
beginning to reflect this kind of
apocalyptic vision of the future where
increasing numbers of men and women
around the world but primarily in the
West
are saying we cannot bring a child into
the world because the world is going to
end famously AOC sites four years ago
yeah and in 12.
um that the world is getting worse which
is an another falsehood now it doesn't
mean that the world doesn't have
problems the world has God knows how
many problems but compared to when when
you compared us to 20 50 200 years ago
the world is in much better shape yet
somehow people have this notion that the
world is getting worse it is going to
end we are going to run out of resources
we are going to despoil the planet the
plan is going to explode everything and
and and and so increasingly people are
saying we cannot bring a child into the
world that is about to end and so the
point that I mean you think people are
thinking about that well they say so
explicitly it's it's in the book we put
a point to
opinion polls that show that people
really believe that we are heading
towards some sort of a planetary
catastrophe
so Mary what do you tell those people
that are saying because like right now I
think we're at seven billion 900
000 and and growing when it comes we
crossed eight billion in November of
last year okay officially
I think I didn't get the email of the
balloon whatever so but hey Mary what do
you tell these people that are uh
they're concerned about all the natural
resources that that we do have so are
you saying with that growth comes all
the stuff like you know the fake meat
that they're making you know eat bugs
like are you saying that there's enough
natural resources here that will we
could flourish no matter how high this
number is gonna get
oh absolutely
um there is plenty to go around and uh
when shortages do occur within the
market uh mechanism you can always
produce more we produce much more wheat
per acre of land than our ancestors
could that is why we are able to feed
eight billion people around the world
have you noticed that in spite of all of
this population growth so again let's
start with the numbers 1800 Thomas
Jefferson is president of the United
States there is one billion people in
the world today uh Biden is president
for veteran For Worse there is eight
billion people in the world and yet we
are able to feed on all of these people
and actually we are beginning to take
some of the land which we used for
agriculture and we are beginning to
return it to Nature to animals and to
Flora how do we do that we increase
weight production or yield on one acre
of land this is how you do it
if you're running out of fish we are
currently running out of fish in the
wild much of many of much of the ocean
is becoming depopulated of fish what do
you do you turn to aquaculture you start
breeding fish in ponds 50 of all of our
fish consumption now is
uh fish grown specifically for the
purpose of being eaten so we don't catch
them in the wild and hopefully we can
get to 100
should at some point in the future
should it happen that I don't know we
are going to somehow run out of cattle
or chicken well we are just going to
grow cells of chicken or or beef in in
huge bots of
um of of liquid and we are going to
produce food that way it's not going to
be it's not going to be impossible food
this is actually going to be you'll be
eating a steak actual steak yeah it just
happened to be grown from a cell of
probably a fantastic cow yeah so all of
those listeners out there who always
wanted to eat a while ago steak but
cannot afford it because it's it costs
300 one day we'll be able to take the
genes or the or the cells from the best
cows in the world maybe the ones from
Japan and everybody will have a steak
for five or ten dollars I can't wait so
so that's what I'm saying is that is
that is that the the amount of resources
in the world is only subject to human
knowledge it's human knowledge that
matters because we can always create
more we can grow more is your contention
that
with population growth you know we're at
8 billion we were at 1 billion in 1800
years ago plus that the more people the
more Minds there are that's a more
technological advancements will come of
it the more you know you get smarter
more efficient more innovative
and better things will happen because
there's more people not despite it that
that is the fundamental premise of the
book so you the the thing to to remember
is that not everybody can be an inventor
or an innovator only a small fraction of
humans will ever invent or innovate
anything it's it's in single digits it's
probably around five or six percent but
everyone reaps the benefits of those
Innovations
precisely I mean I wish to God that we
could have eight billion own must the
world would look very different but we
don't but by but my point is that six
percent out of population of 300 million
people who lived at the time of Christ
or Caesar Augustus really the world's
population was 300 million or or six
percent of one billion people who lived
at a time of Jefferson is still much
smaller total number than if you have a
population of 8 billion people so if
that fraction of humans who innovate
stays the same
then obviously you're going to have many
more people like that in a population of
8 billion and and it is these people who
have it's only human mind currently that
can produce new ideas it is new ideas
that you can turn into inventions then
those inventions get tested in the
marketplace to separate bad inventions
from good inventions the VHS from uh
betamax uh you know
um uh and the the diet coke from Crystal
Coke or whatever it was called I can't
remember that uh the traband from a
Ferrari and and and you will end up
basically with innovations that increase
productivity human productivity and
therefore our standards of living I want
to go back to what Pat sort of
questioned you on was uh about whether
or not whether it's the media whether
it's politicians whoever it is
mainstream media that is trying to
convince people not to have kids what I
want to kind of hone in on is America
and Western civilizations
I want to know what percentage is white
college educated women who are basically
saying I'm done with having kids on this
dream of being a a mother a housewife a
homemaker is it's not for me I just want
to work and make money and then that is
leading to sort of population decline
can you hone in on that so I don't know
the numbers because the studies that I
have seen the public opinion posts have
not been broken down by race or
political
political persuasion
but
just go with your gutter no but what I
can tell you what I can tell you is that
uh the the Richer the society becomes
the the higher you go up the
Maslow hierarchy of needs you know at
the bottom you have your clothing your
food your water your security and at the
top you have self-actualization and
basically what tends to happen is that
it is in societies where people are
extremely rich and again we are
extremely rich by historical standards
where people have all this time and all
this money to
um basically devote themselves to pet
projects such as
um I don't know I I want to live in the
United States where all the plastic is
banned or I want to transform the United
States into
a society where uh that there are no
guns or where there are abortions and
things like that the point is people
have all this time and all of these
resources to to pursue their pet project
now the Pet Project can be good the Pet
Project can be bad but it's only rich
people who have this who have this
amount of time to do that yeah can you
pull up uh Maslow's a hierarchy of needs
hierarchy of needs so yeah it's very
interesting because I want to I want to
get your opinion on essentially what you
said I interviewed this you remember the
freedom Forum it's about Gary Kasparov
yes yes okay so I was invited there via
Pat Uh a year and a half ago and
um
I interviewed who is essentially I
forgive me I forgot his name he
basically hosts The Daily Show but of
Iraq oh really he's a comedian humorous
satire
uh and I said what's your biggest wish
for the people of Iraq and you know you
would assume you know living under no
fear and tyrannical governments and he
says my wish is for them to just come
home every night and watch reality TV
and that'd be the biggest thing on their
mind I said why what are you talking
about he says do you understand how
lucky you are in America to go to your
job to work to just live your life do
what you want to do and come home and
have the freedom to just watch
meaningless dribble on TV because you're
not concerned that a bomb is coming over
your head that someone in your family is
going to get dragged out of the house
for having dissenting political views
and just you're not you know scraping by
for food Water Shelter any of the basic
human needs on the Maslow's hierarchy of
needs and he goes my wish is for the
people of Iraq to just watch the
Kardashians mind-numbingly mindless yeah
but he goes unfortunately we can't do
that life's tough and that was such a
stark example of like holy that's
how where we're at in America today we
have life is so easy it's so good that
our biggest issue is like whether Chloe
lost four pounds today on the
Kardashians pregnant or not Ariana's
whatever it is and it just things are so
good here in the West in America that it
it's almost manifesting like things are
so bad because we have so much time to
focus on minor things that don't affect
day-to-day life yeah is that essentially
your premise yes and and it gets a
little bit worse than that and in a
sense that you see at the top of the
pyramid things are only Zero Sum
um at the bottom of the pyramid if you
have freedom if you have people they are
going to provide for water food shelter
through normal Market mechanism right
we have sort of tackled that particular
that level at the mass of the Maslow
pyramid pyramid of needs
um back in maybe like the 40s or the 50s
um
but again the market can provide more
food more shelter more sleep Innovation
growth Etc but at the top of the pyramid
the problem with self-actualization
where it becomes zero-sum is that your
idea what a perfect Society may be may
may be in direct conflict with mine yeah
so maybe you're prioritizing uh equality
uh of outcome uh over my prioritization
of Liberty and the ability to succeed or
fail within the market system and so
when when we are at the top of the
pyramid and you insist that everybody
should have equality of outcome that
affects me negatively immediately
because it means that I have to forego
something if I'm better off than you are
and that's what leads to social conflict
I think that's part of the reason why we
are at each other's throats is because
we are all at the top of the pyramid but
we have very different ideas about how
the world should be structured in the
west because life is so easy yeah about
how America should fund by the way Pat
what was they do this sort of like
debate I don't know if it's in Cambridge
or in Oxford it's in the UK and they had
this comedian come on and basically sort
of clown wokeness constantly did you see
this yeah Constantine kissing he runs a
podcast okay yeah you've seen it okay
yes I have I don't know if you can pull
that up Rob what a prime example of this
because he basically you talked about
like bowing to the idol of greenness
what was the terminology you used just
like the green religion yeah the green
religion eco-fanatics and he said let me
tell you why the the the the climate
change and the in the global uh
catastrophe is Never Gonna nobody's
gonna work on it can you go back to that
Maslow's hierarchy of needs and he
basically said you have literally
billions of people
in all around the world India China
third world countries Africa you know
Middle East who are still on the bottom
level
who are still just fighting for air
water food shelter all that
and here you are at the top of the
pyramid
self-actualizing what a green new world
would be that's right because it's never
going to happen because you have
billions of people just fighting for the
basics the basics of survival meanwhile
you're over here basically on your you
know iPad in your air-conditioned home
in your college education and just sort
of looking down on people because they
they're they won't take climate change
as seriously as you when they're
literally fighting for their basic needs
in survival and that was the guys I
think I think his entire premise kissing
uh so I would I would sort of divide the
world into two parts one is the
developing or the underdeveloped world
and they are obviously not going to buy
into the whole decarbonization of the
economy wherever you stand on on fossil
fuels or Green Technology the fact is we
are going to use we are going to need
fossil fuels for many more years to come
because they are the cheapest and so the
people who are still very poor say most
of Africa most of Latin America
much of Asia these people are going to
be using those sorts of fuels more than
half the world uh well over of the world
um and then and then the other part of
the world the the Western World
um also generally tends to be Democratic
and so what we are basically saying is
that
um we are asking
um or rather the greens are asking us to
democratically elect
for us to be poorer right and I think
that the much of the conflict in the
west right now has to do with the fact
that in order to implement the green
policies
all of us would have to suffer a great
decline in our standards of living and
that's what's playing out already in
places where the green agenda is most
advanced United Kingdom and Germany
um people are washing themselves in
lukewarm water because they cannot
afford hot water they cannot Heat their
homes in the middle of winter Europe is
much further ahead of where we are
heading if we embrace the same policies
the same green policies we are just
going to be much poorer or alternatively
we are going to elect governments that
are going to behave in a very different
fashion yeah so let me ask you a
question about this the book how much
how much research did you guys do with
the book in regards to what religion has
the most kids which countries are the
most optimistic which states are growing
and not grown within the states what
climates causes people to have more kids
because some of the content that I'm
looking at right now is contradictory
did you did you go into looking at which
religions are having a more kid most
kids why we didn't look we didn't look
at religion the book is devoted
specifically to answering the question
whether more people are going to exhaust
global resources yeah I I guess I I get
that and what I would want to know is so
so here's I just sent you a bunch of
links so go to the one with go to the
abortion one that we looked at as well
as well earlier which country has you
have the link up there one of them which
shows which one of the countries is
having the most abortions today and who
was at the top by a mile it was Russia
then it was Vietnam I think was number
two and it wasn't even close it was 53
percent
to uh 32 percent go a little lower go a
little lower yeah there you go so Russia
was at the top 50 37 Vietnam was 35 and
then you have a few different countries
there and then if you go lower you'll
see well where U.S is at go uh go all
the way to the bottom where you have the
different list of uh countries it should
have U.S there as well is it does it
have it or no if you go all the way to
the bottom
um
there you go that's the list okay 20.8
so we're still up there uh you know
China has 24.2 percent of the population
that's getting abortions but we're still
up there at 21 China is forcing you to
get an abortion here we're not forcing
you you're choosing and we're at 21
right okay so then I said okay why would
you why why would Russia have abortion
as high as they do you said they don't
they're not optimistic about the future
right to see like what the future looks
like is the future bright or not so
because of that they don't want to have
the kids because they don't think it's a
safe environment to have the kids right
then I went to the optimistic most
optimistic country in the world and if
you go to that one I sent you the link
to that as well you have it in the top
right yes one of them that said the
there you go zoom zoom just zoom in in
this one which is kind of weird
pessimism is an optimism
the uh go zoom in just on that charge of
statista yeah it shows that China more
than things are getting better in the
world than are getting worse China is at
the highest level 86 percent there's no
way this data is accurate to show China
is the most optimistic country in the
world according to the their data but
that's exactly what this is the church
India is second and it's Saudi Arabia
then it's Malaysia now look at the one
at the top over the last year the world
has become more dangerous people are
more afraid Colombia 91 Peru
90 South Korea 88 Lucas fourth U.S yeah
it's 86
meaning us is more pessimistic right now
than optimistic right now I'd love to
see where Russia's on the leaders
bulletin here if you can even go to the
bottom or not to see if there is a
Russia here or not on the bottom and
then it broke it down by this okay zoom
in a little bit to see what Russia's out
with this Russia's right there minus
four percent so what's their score if
we're at 86
uh what do you see us on that list
minus four okay Russia is also minus
four okay where we're at but what does
that mean minus four of what though 34
gray somewhat agree when you really
think about it the more things are
getting better in the world these days
than are getting worse nope Americans
don't believe things are getting better
Chinese think things are getting better
hence they're at the top okay so then I
wanted to find out a little bit more
about uh if you go to the next one I
sent you which religion has the most
kids okay
and the change in global religious
landscape babies born and Muslims will
begin to outnumber Christian births by
2035 okay and people with no religion
face a birth dearth okay great name so
uh babies born to Muslims you're 20 so
show the data there show the data go a
little bit lower so we can see that
there you go so Christians read Muslims
green Christians are not having babies
like they once were having and Muslims
are having more babies so if this is
from Pure research and you got to trust
pure research they don't they're not on
one side or the other they're just going
to give you the data that they have
they're they don't it's facts it's not
CNN or Fox so go a little lower to see
if there's any more data to look at here
uh go a little Lord to see if we have
anybody else okay there you go so let's
look at this one here estimator shares
of birth and deaths compared to with
their shared number of overall 2015
population Christians make up the
largest share of 2010. that's Muslims a
larger share of birds okay if you look
at that number 31 one percent to 21 but
Christians there's more dying than being
born Muslims that have 10 percent more
being born than dying and then if you
look at the disparity by 25 and 26 26
2055 and 2060. okay Muslim religion is
going to get bigger than Christians in
the world because Muslims are having
more kids if I'm a Christian leader at
the top and I'm a leader of a thousand
churches I'm probably having this
conversation with my community by the
way shout out to Mormons for having more
kids yeah they're growing their base
more I know this this could be kind of
funny like we're being funny about it
I'm actually not yeah I think if you
really want to your competition is
having more kids than you are okay and
there's going to be more population
there to impose their way of thinking of
course and believe in and they're gonna
outnumber you yeah okay so Christians
hey go make some babies today because
that number is not looking good for you
then go to the next one that I sent to
you which was what causes population to
increase by the way this entire time
while you guys are talking I mean I've
been looking at stuff actually really
curious to know what the hell is going
on here with this I'd like to revisit
that optimism we'll come back to it so
go and just Google the following just
Google in another page Google largest
population of religion you just put
largest religion population so all the
way at the top Christianity right now is
what first place 2.382 it ain't gonna be
there for too long no it's not Muslims
are 1.907 which is 25 and then you have
the rest secular and then you have
Hindus on 1.161 hit more Rose rub
you trying to see Jews I'm just trying
to see my people where we're at yeah
give them some recognition competition
yet
try to wipe us out zoom in 14.7 million
I don't know if you guys realize what
pat pat you made a really good point
once that shift starts happening it's
the and people don't think about it I'm
not saying good or bad thing but this is
this is a Christian country by a big
percentage the the policies
Judea Christian but think about this all
the all the people all the decisions all
the all the Mayors all the everything
bro it's going to be a complete shift on
the religion that runs and you're gonna
see change you know what's crazy you
know what's crazy the average person's
watching this right now the average
listener listening to this right now
they're like who cares about this yeah
yeah you don't care about it you're 42
years old yeah you got your job you're
laughing maybe it's like ah it's not a
big deal oh 40 years from now you will
see how different things will look when
you look at Congress 30 of Congress are
going to be Muslims and you know 30 of
senators and then all of a sudden U.S
has a Muslim uh president and then hey
what's wrong with that nothing's wrong
with that and now you know the the it
the and this isn't to fear that this
isn't to fear that this is if you have a
certain belief and you have a lot of
pride in that well then show up and make
some babies and raise some leaders and
inject your philosophy into this because
Muslims get a shout out for absolutely
doing that better than Christians are
doing it right now the the stat that you
just showed was that for the world or
the United States world population okay
so so I don't think that has a uh direct
effect on on the United States in the
sense that well in a sense that
our Muslim population would have to
would have to grow at an even faster
rate than that because most of our
immigrants are actually coming to the
country but from other Christians
Nations such as Catholics from from
Latin America
say that one more time well most of the
immigration into the United States most
of the population growth is happening in
uh within the within the Hispanic
Community they've grown which is 24 yeah
yes 24 but uh uh when when you when you
have a long-term thinking mindset and
your opponent does not it's just a
matter of time until you infiltrate
universities until you infiltrate
educational system until you infiltrate
school systems until you infiltrate
build in churches until you infiltrate
politics until you infiltrate media
until you they're already doing it right
now anyways and by the way this isn't a
if you're if you're Muslim and you're a
leader of Islam your kudos to you
strategically Christians are sitting on
the sidelines being very casual about it
and it's almost like the competitor that
thinks ah it's not a big deal you know
they're never going to pass us up okay
brace for impact because it's going to
come very very quickly and when it hits
you the difference between Muslims and
Christians is what the other day this
Dar what's his name the football player
who wore that jacket in the uh wore that
jacket at Super Bowl did you see the
jacket he wore mocking Jesus yeah yeah
dude
the guy that almost died on the field
yeah and he was praying what yeah and
the AOC said something he wears this
jacket mocking Jesus and you know what
is that yeah so he wears this jacket
after he was praising Jesus you know who
called him out Adrian Peterson pulls him
out and tweets about and says what kind
of a thing are you wearing and then some
you know there's stuff in football right
now saying you should tell them that
privately you shouldn't tell them that
publicly Adrian Peterson's like what are
you doing what is the guy that almost
lost his life the guy that was like oh
you should be freaking the guy that the
first thing was Lord gloves me and the
God was looking at me and then he did
that so but here's a point though here's
the point somebody here's what they're
gonna say though someone's gonna say oh
grow up guys this is called Art yeah
this is called Art really no problem why
don't you do the same art in Prophet
Muhammad and let's see if you'll call
that art as well I'm wearing the Super
Bowl go ahead and do that but here's a
point here's the point the point is
Christians tend to be forgiven and they
say let it slide Muslims are not no they
don't play games and say let it slide so
there is that standard and expectation
where if somebody sits let's just say
you have two kids one kid you joke with
he takes it the other kid you joke with
he says don't do that again that I don't
like that when you do that in front of
people okay guess whose standard you're
going to step up to as a parent the kid
that tells you don't make fun of me in
front of my friends that's exactly
what's happening here one religion's
like ah it's okay let it slide the other
religion's like no don't do it so not
only are they growing faster they're
more disciplined they believe more they
have higher standard and expectations of
their members there is a more
disciplined way of what you need to do
on a daily basis praying the the level
of commitment to that religion is much
higher 100 so that's what they're
injecting and they're gonna figure out a
way to get into different communities
but here's the part if you go the
article I sent you about Netherlands I
sent you an article about Netherlands
how they said why population grows and
why it goes on did you see the one I
sent you
uh this could be the one it's got to be
dot NL this is the one okay so I'm
trying to find that so causes and
effects of population decline when
people move away from Villages only in
Netherlands they use the word villages
we don't use that in America but
apparently they do Villages job schools
shops and other facilities also
disappear the government needs to tackle
the causes and effects of population
decline for instance by cutting down on
a number of new homes being built what
okay so cause the population decline go
to the bottom here we go some
demographic population few children are
being born Bingo families and with
children move to larger towns and cities
okay young and better educated people
move to larger towns and cities fine so
the current and projected population
decline look at the list it gives here
go a little lower it's got like 10 lists
there right on the on the bottom keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going there you go so let me read
the top Bullet To The Top yeah it says
what affects the population when young
people move to bigger towns and cities
the average age of population the place
they leave behind automatically goes up
very interesting we just learned
something that makes sense let me read
that one more time when young people
move to bigger towns and cities the
average age of the population the place
they left behind automatically goes up a
community with a higher power proportion
of older inhabitants may be less
attractive to businesses which may
additionally have difficulty finding
suitable staff locally other effects of
population decline include fewer schools
due to their being fewer children a drop
in house prices because more homes are
unoccupied fewer new homes are being
built you're contradicting yourself less
demand for rented accommodation fewer
care facilities less turnover for
shopkeepers and businesses
fewer sports facilities fewer people
going to a theater cinema concerts or
the facilities are eventually cut back
fewer people traveling by public
transport and local residents have to
travel further to reach the facilities
they want
obviously we're not Netherlands but they
they're leaving certain clues of what
happens when people are moving to other
cities and other places the other day
when I was talking to Roland Martin and
he says well you know here's what's
going on with these cities and I said
why'd you leave your city everybody else
is leaving so I left
okay but you left behind you're another
high Money Maker that could have
increased the
you know value of properties in that
Community but you left right so what
causes this one of is how many babies we
have
two could be our educational system what
the kids are being fed three could be
our religion four could be what kind of
immigrants are we attracting the
immigrants were attracting to U.S from
South and Central America thank God they
make babies right because they don't
have a problem making babies maybe some
some immigrants that come in are not
making babies maybe you by the way it
would be very interesting to even look
at the data wrap I don't even know if we
can pull this up
to see who makes the most babies in
America like if we were to do Hispanic
baby per family average versus whites
versus blacks versus Middle Easterns
versus Asians
I'd be so curious to know or you can
just put in birth rate by race in the
United States rate by there you go there
we go
Mary knows what he's talking about so
let's see this here
uh that's percentage I'd love to know
percentage of birth the Latinos
yeah but that's not given the right
stats though that's given them of course
that number is going to be
52.1 percent that's why there's more
white people yeah I want to understand I
want to know per
I want to know per family so instead of
uh uh what do we put white race uh
birth rate
how would you put it senses your world
how would you put it
you could try uh birth rate by race per
hundred thousand
okay that's better birth rate by Race by
a hundred thousand by the way Marion has
hired full-time research yeah he's uh
congratulations offer's been made we can
we can we can fire our friend chat GPT
if we if we'd like or keep him
number of birth total fertility I would
their total fertility
rate by ethnicity in 2020. why don't you
that one what's your
what's your prediction here what's your
it's not even a prediction I'm willing
to tell you I don't think whites are
having that many kids per uh uh uh what
is it Asians or 1.385 000 women okay
interesting there you go Hispanics 2.145
1.41
uh okay Hispanics are two no no what
you're what you're saying is Pacific
Islander they they have the most right
Pacific Islanders number one number two
is Hispanic number three is blacks
you see I told you whites are not having
that many kids
white people Step It Up Guys Step It Up
by by the way by the way I'm telling you
this is Rob scrolling a little bit this
seems like a regular thing I'm telling
you whites are not having enough kids
but you see who's last place here Asians
the Asians yeah he was talking about
China they're not banging oh this is in
the United States oh that's the United
States what's going on well I mean it's
in the culture if you talk about it or
there's a major shrinkage issue going on
no he said he said there's a shrinkage
in the population well it's kind of like
Jerome Powell upstairs banging on the on
the drum of the uh yeah interest rates
yeah
interesting so native Hawaiian Pacific
Islanders having the most kids per
capita right and then you have Hispanic
and then you have black Americans and
then all sort of the median and then the
the bottom tier are whites non-hispanic
uh American Indians and then Asians by
Far and Away last place what's the
correlation there Marion
well I I can only guess
um and uh my guess would be that uh a
lot of Asian women actually
um go to universities and get graduate
and postgraduate degrees and so you
would expect their
um uh their uh
their average age of having the first
baby to be quite old yeah good point
that would be my that would be my guess
so the more educated you are the more
free you are the lower your chances of
wanting to have kids be a family woman
or a family person early or in general
period yeah I mean obviously the later
you start having children the the fewer
you're going to end up with and a lot of
uh these couples
um certainly I'm aware of
a little bit about the Asian situation
uh would be people who would start
having babies maybe even in their
mid-30s so by the time that your you are
advised not to have any more children
you may be 40 and you are able to only
have one child so this may be sort of a
naive question but is it I guess bad for
women to continue education because it
seems like it's
limiting growth my view population my
view is that parents should have as many
children as they want what I don't want
is for Parental choices to be impacted
by crazy millennarian
Cult of the Apocalypse this is this is
this is the uh this is the Eco
um apocalypse that we have been told
about every day so there are many
reasons for which people have babies and
there are many reasons for which people
don't have babies
um women's choice is obviously quite
important as well but if if we are going
to commit civilizational suicide because
we are being told that the world is
going to end in eight years and people
shouldn't have babies that I have a
problem with and that's what the book is
dedicated to is just to remove one Brick
in the Wall
um of of a barrier against against
people having children this this kind of
opens up that dialogue of optimism
versus pessimism if you would I'm sure
you've written a whole book about this
it would seem to me and you have all the
data people are living longer people are
getting out of poverty there's more
drinking water there's more supplies
there's more Commodities like the world
is getting better you know life
expectancy a hundred years ago was 45 50
years old whatever it was now it's 75.80
you know I think you know a hundred
years ago what 70 of the world was in
dire poverty now it's less than 10
percent you have all the stats I'm gonna
let you do your thing but it seems to me
the world is getting better and better
and better and better people are living
longer people are more prosperous yet
there's this like fake narrative that
we're all gonna die soon yeah so
extrapolate okay so so let's get a few
statistics
um
for as far back as we can tell people
earned two dollars per person per day or
less that was that was that was a global
average or or the or the proactive
equivalent thereof about two dollars per
person per day today globally uh average
daily income is forty dollars per person
per day okay and so it went from 2 to 40
in how long uh well uh
in the last 200 years okay until about
1800 the the world income was Industrial
Revolution pretty much pretty much
stagnant if two dollars per person per
day you can take it back 2 000 years ago
or ten thousand years ago it would still
be the same in the last 200 years and
that's a global average obviously in the
United States we have much richer our
income per day is something like hundred
and eighty dollars per person per day on
average again
um so again in 1800 90 of people live on
two dollars per person per day or less
um uh
um today it's down to about eight or
nine percent
uh as late as 1900 so the presidency of
Theodore Roosevelt in the richest
countries in the world life expectancy
was 50 years
today around the world it's uh 72 years
in the United States it's 78 years and
in some countries it's even even higher
um roughly half of babies who were born
died in infancy before the age of one or
before the age of five
um half of all babies would die up to
half and that was it that was in what
year well uh 1700s 1700s in in Sweden
for example we have very good records
for Sweden so the between one third and
a half but there could be years in which
half of newborns and what's that number
today around the world globally well uh
in in in in the most developed countries
it would be in low single digits uh
let's say around two to five percent now
that's not just because of lack of care
I mean you know kids come into the world
with all sorts of
um you know some kids with all sorts of
defects and they die unfortunately but
but it's much much lower
um
so so that was that was the world before
and I think that part of the reason for
this uh tremendous amount of negativity
about the future of America in the
western civilization it's not just this
green apocalypse that we have been told
about every day but also that nobody is
singing the Praises of the American
experiment or the Western experiment
overall uh right now in the United
States we don't really have a
constituency
praising
um president of the United States I'll
tell you why it may be counter-intuitive
but I think you see when you have a
republican in charge all the Democrats
say the world is going to end this is
the worst thing that could have happened
he's the new Hitler but the same thing
oddly enough happens when you have a
democrat in charge is the Republicans
say the country is in permanent decline
look at this Joker in charge you know
he's obviously senile country has never
been worse off so the point is that that
in order to get people excited about
voting is to piss them off is to make
them angry and the only way you can do
it is by saying everything is going to
hell and both parties do that nobody is
saying that the country is doing well
ever ever is that unique to America or
is that just a political agenda on all
countries
I'm most familiar with the United States
and this political polarization where
you cannot admit that the other party is
doing even one percent right right that
that I think is specifically unique to
us right
um the other things that are happening
of course you've got the rise of the CRT
and attacks on on free speech and and
part of the critical race Theory
business is that is that it attacks the
founding of the United States America is
very different from Western Europe or
from Europe where I'm from in the united
in in in Western Europe or in Europe in
order to become a member of the tribe so
to speak you have to be born into that
Nation you have to be born check or you
have to be born Slovak or you have to be
born German to be properly understood as
that but in the United States we don't
work like that we have our constitution
right we don't know her kings queens we
don't even have that longer history but
we do have the Constitution
um and the founding documents and the
founding fathers and right now in the
United States what we are seeing is a
concentrated attack on everything that
until two seconds ago was considered to
be somewhat sacred which is to say the
founding and the revolution
1619 project versus the 1776 project is
a perfect example of that
so
so you basically no longer if people ask
you well then what was the good part of
of America you cannot actually say
because in every part of of our American
history there has always been somebody
who was not doing terribly well or
somebody who was discriminated against
or whatever so on that basis
we can really no longer say that
anything in America works because it is
Tainted by uh by this by this history
that the CRT put at the center of its
philosophy hmm uh are you saying that
you're not willing to make America great
again
I
I'm saying that America was great is
great and can be even greater I love
that uh
this lack of patriotism right I think
something an issue that I have with the
Democratic side of the aisle is if you
see a flag
over someone's house yes or on their
bumper sticker or someone wearing a a an
American flag hat yes what political
party would you most likely affiliate
you assume they are Republican because
you would assume they're Republican yeah
because they have an American flag that
to me is ludicrous and and because
there's a there seems to be a large
contingency on the left the far left who
genuinely hates
the concept of America the 1619 project
my point would be the only way you can
hate America is the is if if the if your
diet of news or whatever you are reading
or learning only focuses on the bad
things in American history but of course
every country in the world has some sort
of a terrible past every every
civilization in world history had
slavery for example I mean this is a
topic that Americans talk about more
than anything else and uh the reality is
that it's always been there and until
200 years ago it never occurred to
anybody that you could have there was
not a sustained movement anywhere in the
world for the abolishment of slavery
until Britain in seven in late 1700s so
I I think it is quite wrong to uh to to
focus just on that as opposed to all the
all the good things that America has
done including providing very high
standards of living for the people of of
all colors and immigrants and immigrants
like but you have to agree though that
Anti-Flag American sentiment I did not
see it until six years ago as a veteran
as a proud American as you know my whole
family served in the military pants a
veteran I didn't start seeing that at
all ever until Trump was in and the flag
in America they were they had to do the
opposite of whatever Trump was saying
and that's where that started that
looking at flag that that what do you
what do you proud what are you so proud
of We Come From Slavery and we're this
country is and that's why all those
gens whatever it was a disease they've
been bombarded with hey this country
hates you we come from and no
that's not great no doubt a large part
of it was Trump I think it was in Prior
with Obama but I mean a lot of it
started with bush too let me bring you
back to to having kids okay we we just
we had a Super Bowl party at the new
building that we you know bought and we
turn it into a nice little Lounge you
know Cigar Lounge which is going to be
launched by the way it's going to be
private it's not gonna be open to
everybody but it looks insane it looks
insane the inside of it's like a uh a
place uh anyways I'm not even gonna go
into it but it's looking forward to
having some meetings there with people
but we're having a late night
conversation it's like 1 30 in the
morning we're talking to these different
guys okay
and we're having a conversation about
the most sensitive topics one of the
guys is there you know who he is he's
Muslim but he's very conservative yeah
and he's a republican okay
and uh uh then you got Democrats
Republicans you got uh blacks Asia it
doesn't matter we have them all in that
room at night it's like 25 of us sitting
having a good conversation together and
then the conversation comes about of
having having kids right and I said uh
there's a reason why I don't like the
one person said well we just want to
have one kid because I'm the only child
and I just want to have one kid and
that's what I want to do I said like
that's the worst thing you can do
okay he says why do you say that I said
you know it's the same reason why I
didn't just get one dog
yeah and says why I said if a dog
doesn't have another dog to play with
you are the dog
friend so he can talk to I don't want
you to lick my legs I don't want you to
smell my butt I don't want you to hump
my legs go do it to another dog yeah
right so by the way it's the graphics
here can we just make a quote of Pat
saying I am not a dog okay so so the
same the same reason why one shouldn't
have just one kid unless if that's God's
plan if it's God's plan it is what it is
or you can't have another kid because
you got lucky and got one you just again
you can't get pregnant because you
started very late it is what it is I
don't recommend having only one kid I
don't recommend having only one duck I
don't recommend having only one anything
except for wife okay all right and by
the way happy birthday babe and Happy
Valentine's Day it's her birthday today
and it's Valentine's Day he's gonna
mention there you go there you go happy
birthday happy birthday Jen Happy
Valentine's Day all right so
so that's that part so now kids then we
start talking about kids I said if you
make money
and financially you can afford kids
you should keep having kids now the room
the room is filled with Half Men and
half women obviously the wives are not
happy about this it's like who do you
think you are you know all this other I
they love me I love them we're like
family it's like you wouldn't at the
level of camaraderie we have is at the
highest level but they'll say of course
come on Pat what are you talking about
so I'm telling you
if you have the resources and you're a
leader and you're teaching people on
reading books developing the right
values the right principles you should
have kids the problem is people who
shouldn't have kids are having seven
kids
people who shouldn't have kids keep
having kids can't afford it they're not
reading they're not developing they're
not teaching they're not making the
society a better place so we keep having
kids by the people that are not
necessarily developing the next layer of
leaders in the future so but if somebody
can't afford like you with this guy you
know if you if you're smart if you're
wise if you can bring value if you can
teach somebody how to make money and be
be a better net positive to society
let's go
let's go and by the way and by the way
you know you know you know what would
happen if and by the way maybe there's a
reason for it but if if I'm if I'm the
president of the United States yeah I am
telling you we'd be having
record-breaking years the four years I'm
president America would have more babies
than any eight year period what would be
your what would be your slow like well
how would you push that agenda
my agenda is going to be make money
become a leader then duplicate
okay not just make babies to make babies
make money become a leader then go
duplicate not just go make babies
stopped it would be stop netflixing and
chilling start reading a damn book or
watch documentaries create a criteria
for yourself for every one movie or show
you get to watch you have to watch three
documentaries
so if you're going to watch a show
or you're going to watch some movies
watch three documentaries if you're
going to read one romance novel read two
business books if you're into like I
know he's big on these 50 Shades of Gray
type of rhyme every time I buy you
Jessica he's got these Romance Books
right I mean it's just he's a hardcore
romance you know for every one of those
read a couple business books gotcha read
a couple biographies yeah go out there
and start a side gig make some more
money do something for yourself and your
family become a leader in the company
that you're building get yourself to a
point where you know you are a big net
positive to the company then guess what
make babies and a lot of them and don't
stop okay
this is like you know people are
probably listening to this in St Pat's
lost his mind okay I bet I bet 80 of
people that are listening to me right
now saying Pat's crazy I don't know what
he's on it's he's only saying this
because it's Valentine's Day today yeah
he's in the love
baby making wood or whatever you want to
call it trust me if I had it my way I
would have 20 kids I am telling you I'd
have 20 kids I'd be the guy calling Casa
D'Angelo saying we'd like to make a
reservation how big is your party party
of 24. shut it down yeah
got it that last room is closed I love
it matter of fact let's name this room
what do we need to do to do that I want
that right and obviously we started late
but it is what it is so again if this
was a source of inspiration for somebody
listen to this I didn't tell you to have
kids right now I told you go become a
leader make some money have the right
values and principles then go okay go
let somebody else use condoms you you
say moving forward we're going on a
four-year run yeah we're going on a
six-year run babe let's go make some
babies okay uh and by the way if if
you're saying this is crazy your
competitors are doing this just so you
know America America your competition
right now while you're talking
getting your four-year degree in Fine
Arts they're making babies Yep they're
making babies and you're learning about
Fine Arts yeah that's what they're doing
they are making babies anyways I'm a
little upset about the necessary stuff
right listen campaign campaign slogan
2024 pbd Let's Get It On America okay
but remember remember what I said the
whole concept is
I'm not telling you go not out of
wedlock find somebody that can make a
good mom or a good father and a good
husband and then and then go from there
but I'm telling you if you can if you
have the ability if you're a leader let
a rip let's go uh anyways let's go into
some topics yeah this podcast been a
very weird it's Valentine's Day I mean
it's your wife's birthday you're allowed
to have a uh an emotional moment it's
allowed it is it is I never get
emotional I never show emotions everyone
knows if you think this is emotional you
have lost your mind if you think this is
emotion anyways okay let's go on some
stories Vinnie why don't you tell us
what's going on with uh you know Houston
matter of fact can you have that
explosion in in Palestine Ohio so we can
just see this and then how it's being
spun and what we're being told about it
I don't think this is the one that's the
one in the Hiroshima uh that one right
let's just watch this go ahead Vinnie
well I want to say one thing uh just
like you said with the with the spot
this past month spy balloons the uh
defense secretary Lloyd Austin said that
there's three objects taken down that
were not spy balloons so a lot of
speculation people like well they kind
of distracting us and you know there's
gonna be conspiracy theories but the
same token Wednesday tomorrow the
Epstein all the files of everything with
Jeff Epstein are supposed to be coming
out so everybody's playing the
conspiracy thing but I want to talk
about Pete butterjudge the transfer
Secretary of Transportation well well
how many how many mistakes can this one
guy do from the supply chain crisis that
we had from the airports the the
disaster during uh the holidays so now
this is the third train and you want to
talk about how distracted people are
with Rihanna on pregnancy I walked into
our office today and Adam you might have
been one of the people I was like yo did
you hear about the the train that dumped
thousands of gallons of uh the vinyl
chlorine you you didn't you didn't know
about it no it's one of the ecological
like the the disaster that it's caused
uh it's like apparently all this uh
chemicals fell down they made a decision
to just burn it and the look of what
happened in the town it looked like a
nuclear blast do we have the video
there's definitely a video look just
watch the video Yeah show this
this is the initials
high in northeastern Ohio the evacuation
order just press yeah there you go yeah
five for mind you so 5 000 people
evacuated it's they're not they're not
really talking about it pat they're
saying that a guy let his dog out to get
water five minutes later dog dropped
dead miles and miles away from the look
look at that tell me what does that look
like Pat that's like True by the way
that's from a plane airplane yeah so
mind you thousands of fish fish are
dying and this just this just goes to
show you bro uh this is when you hire
just for diversity because you know he's
the head of Transportation how many
times can this guy drop the ball the
only reason people got that job and I'm
being straight up is because he's a gay
man there's no zero Patrick zero
qualifications Rob go on his Wikipedia
what is what does Pete bootage know
about Transportation mind you this is
the same guy drives a car that that 100
same guy during the supply chain crisis
guess what he did two month maternity
leave with his husband paternity leave
have a little respect whatever it was
for two months while we were going with
that for two once he was gone how many
mistakes like can happen and keep
blowing both this is a disaster you know
what he was yesterday he didn't make one
mention of what's happening this is this
is really really bad guess what he was
talking about diversity in the workforce
he was saying that like when yeah White
Construction there's too many white
construction workers bro people this is
a cancerous thing I saw vehicles that
had the front of their bumpers at him
the stuff is like melting pieces of the
plastic on the car he was talking about
how racism he's on the America's racist
tour that's what he's doing that's what
America is is worried about is that and
he's the main guy same thing with Kamala
when you just hire because it's either
race or the sexual their choice that's
what you get and by the way what
happened so this is this is are you
following the story or no oh this is the
first time yeah but I want to I want to
hear more yeah so so this is Houston
then I'm sorry this is a Palestine Ohio
the next day it's South Carolina if you
have that one uh uh this is this is
South Carolina or this is okay let's
let's see this one
can do you have a clip of it or what is
it shown
is it shown anything or no just that
train right there you would say it
derailed I see it I see it yeah what are
the odds Pat of three separate trains
all derailing all dropping toxic like
really really bad chemicals all in that
and that like that spam and by the way
do you know do you know the county
Palestine Ohio is 70 Republicans they
voted 70 Trump in 2020. but just so you
know that I'll be serious with you yeah
Palestine Ohio
is a very uh uh big Republican town yeah
so I I and by the way I'm not I'm not
going to that so that could be just a
purely coincidence on that taking place
but what what are what are people saying
with the is there is there a common
threat amongst the three uh uh you know
Ohio South Carolina and Houston or no no
and and from from what I did from the
research that I did a lot some you know
some people are are saying like maybe
it's like a Cyber attack where they're
coming like the communication is wrong
that that thing is going on the wrong
track and falling off and then like I
said earlier Pat it's like almost like a
coincidence when people are like
something about Epstein is coming out
and mind you did you know this Pat
what's coming out about the Epstein
situation Rob is they're going to
release all his business partners all
the suspected uh Predators all his
victims all that P All That is supposed
to come out tomorrow and a lot of a lot
of people are saying that this is just
like the UFO situation because you know
that Pat that's a fact defense secretary
Lloyd Austin said and I quote three
objects taken down this weekend are
totally different from the Chinese Bible
so what is it you can't tell us what
what are these F-16 shooting down if
they're even shooting down anything some
people are saying it's a distraction all
this is a big distraction so you don't
know tomorrow tomorrow's a really really
big day I want to see if it still
happens if the Epstein list is going to
come out well let me ask you this though
I mean if if the people behind it
um have so much power that they are able
to derail trains and
I have UFOs flying around the United
States why wouldn't they have the power
to not to release those documents or to
or to destroy them I mean So based on
your research Vincent well basically yes
no based on my research is it's going to
come out but if you have people
distracted mind you people walked in you
were one of them he was one of them you
guys had no idea that there was
something a controlled substance spewing
into uh on our on American soil that's
gonna definitely cause cancer it's
killing animals it's killing fish nobody
really knows about it so the more they
have you thinking about UFOs people know
more about the spot there's UFOs down
people think nobody knows about the
Epstein thing did you guys even know
that that's coming out tomorrow did you
have any oh absolutely so what I'm
saying is that's a great my point is put
as much distraction as you can out there
because tomorrow when this comes out
nobody's gonna care just like when the
JFK files are coming out people are like
okay we know just like the Twitter files
people get it they're they're on they're
in Congress right now trying to you know
hold these people accountable that were
fired from Twitter but you know what
people's attention in Spanish like it'll
go away is this information going to be
unreducted because I'd be quite
surprised and Rob can you find out if if
the Epstein I I think it's just a list
man I think it's gonna be a list of
everybody that was a victim everybody he
had business dealings with everybody
that was on this island the whole list
is supposed to come out tomorrow but how
do we know everybody who should be on
the list is you know I mean I live in DC
I don't believe anything I don't believe
it you know
if I may yes I just Googled some
information by the way I don't think
there's any
correlation between trained derailments
and Jeffrey Epstein but if you want to
go down that path I want you to research
it what I did do research is uh you know
I used to take the train to work from
Miami to Boca for years
years it was a grind this is part of the
reason I'm a car and once a week someone
was
got hit by a trade like I'm an hour late
to work today I thought I'd get there
early no there's a train issue it's a
train issue so as I'm hearing more about
these trainers I'm like well let's see
how common these things are do your do
your research Beyond this yeah yeah uh
it says how many trained derailments are
in the U.S each year it says while
fatalities from train derailments are
rare derailments themselves are actually
quite common since 1990 the first year
that they began tracking train
derailments and injuries on a yearly
basis up to 2021
uh there have been 54 000 accidents in
which a Train derailed that's an average
of 1700 train derailments per year so it
seems to be freaking common now
obviously I'm going to assume that some
of them are minor of course some of them
are major they seem to be major yeah uh
but I would you I want you to to go
deeper on this okay but here's my here's
my thing Google how many times in one
month less than a month three trains
dropping hundreds of thousands no no
that's what I'm saying that is re this
is not uh
we're in agreement that some weird
has happened the derailment that you're
talking about could be like it hit
another train no doubt but but here my
thing is this I can have an opinion and
my opinion is this past month from Bible
mind you NORAD I don't know what the
hell norad's what's going on they have
no idea they this spy balloon didn't
they didn't track it till it came over
Canada and hit us but guess what if it's
if it's a Santa Claus tracker they're
like hey it's coming over a lot they
know where the Santa Claus tracker is
they don't know what the the goddamn
Chinese spy balloons are and I'm shocked
that we can even call it a Chinese fly
balloon because it's racist to even say
that this thing is coming from over no I
mean it's it's funny but it's not funny
I think I think it's a serious thing
hundreds the thing is still burning that
5 000 uh person sitting uh is evacuated
and those people are making videos and
they're complaining bro because they're
making like it's not a big deal why
isn't the federal government so Vinnie
tie it all together for me what's
happening I'm tying it all together in
that when you have uh the Secretary of
Transportation on the tour telling
people about how there's lack of
diversity why isn't he talking the first
thing he should be talking about is this
problem this is a dude this isn't just
okay they spilled some you know gas and
it's gonna disappear that's it's burning
and these people are getting infected
it's cancerous I think your point
is Pete bootage has some explaining to
do 100 but he'll but they'll never hold
him accountable bro he he has no
business being the head of
Transportation she has no why is she
even speaking the White House Press
Secretary Kamala Harris they're horrible
at their job but nobody holds them
accountable you're not good at your job
if if people did you worked at
McDonald's and he did that many mistakes
he would have been gone on the on the
second fry up question let me ask a
question so out of all the things out of
by the way Pete putitch is not qualified
for this at all I mean you you know he's
not qualified for this job that deal was
made that Tuesday or whatever the day
was when himself Elizabeth Warren Bernie
everybody dropped out and they said uh
Joe Biden is going to be the candidate
and that the day the way that deal was
broken okay I'll step down if you give
me XYZ job hey since you like driving
Teslas you're the transportation guy you
know Kamala you're gonna be this and
you're gonna do this and you're gonna I
don't even know if he drives a Tesla he
may drive a Prius for I know he may
drive a Ford Focus but all I'm saying is
he got a job yeah for the hell of it so
let's let's set it
year uh with what he's doing he's going
to be one of their Superstars just so
you know he's a superstar for the left
yeah um
sometimes when things like this happen
you have to also know like uh you're
distracting the audience which is the
American people from a real issue that
is going on if we go and we think about
the last 30 days or the last two weeks
what's really been the biggest story
that could hit that really could you
know some could go down all right
for example
um North stream pipeline I'm happy to
pick that up you look at North stream
pipeline you know the story that was
written by the two-time Pulitzer uh
Prize winner uh uh Hirsch what's his
first name Seymour her she wrote that
somebody he's had some stories that have
worked against him whatever we're not
sitting here you know we have to give
that as well he's got a couple stories
that he did that actually didn't end up
but he made some claims years ago that
was actually right and he's known for
being the guy that does great
investigative journalism which is what
their job is supposed to be and the
whole story is about what the fact that
U.S was behind North stream pipeline why
would Russia do this to themselves when
they own 50.1 percent of it it's like me
owning a business for 50.1 percent of
business and I blowed up myself and I
need the money and I'm in the middle of
a war with a country called Ukraine that
I used to be my land and I need as much
Resource as possible to fund this war
and yeah let me go blow up my own North
stream pipeline No One Believes that's
possible we know that lady that came out
and texted and says done you know
finished yeah yeah finished and then we
also know when Joe Biden do you have the
clip of what Joe Biden said about the
north stream pipeline when he gave the
answer and the ladies like well how do
you know that how are you so certain do
you remember his answers yes just trust
me just trust me I know you know so no
one's touching this so why why is this
so important why is this so if you can
play this clip give me context because
you're saying because what that guy's
saying is that Navy Seals went in there
underwater Frogman and blew up we blew
up that that pipe yeah that's what he
was saying so we're gonna be honest with
you I'll read the article so please I'll
read the article so you know Pulitzer
Prize winning Seymour harsh uh has
alleged uh has alleged U.S Navy divers
if you have the New York uh post story
if you don't have it I'll text it to you
right now Robin you can pull it up but
I'm going to read it myself while we're
going through this
so uh the story that he is
Navy divers yeah so so you as a U.S Navy
divers laid bombs that destroyed the
Nordstrom to natural gas pipeline under
the Baltic Sea last September drawn a
denial from Pentagon Wednesday Hirsch
who scooped journalism type of words
from five decades ago for exposing the
myeli massacre of Vietnamese civilians
by U.S troops in 1968 cited an unnamed
Source in reporting on substack that
Americans planted remotely triggered
explosive that wreck three of our four
pipeline three of the four pipelines
built to carry natural gas from Russia
to Europe Hirsch 85 want to claim that
the Navy conducted an operation
undercover of a NATO uh Maritime
exercise called ball tops 22. I don't
know if you have the story ball tops 22
in a short statement Pentagon spokesman
Marine Corps Lieutenant Colonel Garen
Garn told the post the United States was
not involved in the Nordstrom explosion
reiterating the defense Department's
response to the same question in October
Swedish officials suspected the ball
blast were the result of gross sabotage
and some Western officials
were quick to blame the attacks on
Moscow do you realize how dumb if you
actually believe yeah for somebody like
say Elon Musk he himself brought down
Tesla and Twitter because he just kind
of felt like yeah right and he when he
owned 51 percent of it if he did okay
and it blocked his cat gas supplies to
Europe in response to sanctions over
last year's Invasion to Ukraine these
are deliberate actions not an accident
Danish Prime Minister met Fredrickson
said at the time the situation is as
serious it gets anyways so these are the
claims that he's making okay and then
Biden gets up and he's asked the
question if he can find this clip if he
can find this clip because all of this
is coming down to the ICBM that just U.S
accidentally practiced just three days
ago launching in Us's government
pentagon is telling everybody to get out
of Russia at a time like this so do you
have the clip of what he says is this
the one okay uh found a clip uh from
Tucker's show where I think okay that's
it that's you it so this is her and him
press both of them play both of them
so this is what she says and at the
state department the number two of the
state department and Joe Biden
threatened to blow up the nordstream
pipeline watch
I want to be clear with you today if
Russia invades Ukraine one way or
another Nordstrom two will not move
forward if Russia invades that means
tanks or troops crossing the uh the the
border of Ukraine again then there will
be uh we there will be no longer on
North stream too we we will bring it
into it
would you but how would you how will you
do that
exactly since the project and control of
the project is within Germany's controls
we will uh I promise you we'll be able
to do it well what does that even so
then the pipe yeah what do you mean I
promise yeah we will be able to do that
yeah you sent two frogmen in there and
that's what interest what interest does
Russia have to do that right think about
the interest of Russia okay what
interest do they have to do that so all
right so I asked a question from you
earlier is this a distraction these
trains are these balloons of
distractions like hey look over here oh
we're dealing with something really
big here here's a story for you nothing
to see here U.S test launches U.S test
launches ICBM into Pacific as part of
nuclear deterrence Mission okay this is
U.S news and World Report okay the U.S
Air Force test launched an unarmed
intercontinental ballistic missile the
Minuteman III into the Pacific Ocean
claiming the launch was a routine a name
that reassuring allies of course it's
just a routine of course the timing is a
little crazy but don't worry people it's
just routine the Air Force Global strike
command asserted the test was intended
to demonstrate that the United States
nuclear and deterrent is safe secure and
reliable and effective to deter 21st
century threats the English language
Global times China state-run newspaper
has suggested China's developing its
nuclear Arsenal faster than the U.S
which possesses a Cold War era stockpile
that is aging and North Korea was also
paraded its large ever collection of
nuclear missiles and Russia has deployed
a warship with hypersonic nuclear
warheads into InterContinental Waters
near the U.S these developments have
alarmed European nations which are
hesitant to supply potent weapons to
Ukraine obviously you know how you go to
like an air show and they're just kind
of entertaining you this is all they're
doing guys folks if you're listening to
this it's just simply a form of
entertainment for for the American
people and what a great timing right
imagine did anybody know that we're
testing like because I'm mind you I
worked at a nuclear missile base in
Mount Storm Air Force Base Montana where
this Chinese spy balloon was just
hovering and not collecting data it was
just it was just flying around and it's
somehow some way and then I'll pause you
and I'll turn it over to you guys and
I'll you know hey if you can go to this
NPR story while all this stuff is going
on while all this stuff again NPR is not
Fox News it's not this is not pry bar
this is not CNN this is NPR NPR is left
leaning government funded media so you
have to realize who NPR is okay the US
is urging Americans to leave Russia
immediately due to security risks the
U.S embassy in Moscow is urging
Americans to leave Russia immediately
due to security res amid the war in
Ukraine the U.S embassy in Moscow warned
the unpredictable consequences of the
war in Ukraine and said that the U.S
Russian citizen has particular risk
being forcibly conscripted into Russia's
armed forces the embassy also cautioned
that Americans in general face potential
harassment or wrongful detention by
Russian Security Services the Kremlin
Shrugged off calls of Americans to leave
the country as not new next week will
mark one year since Russia invaded
Ukraine on February 24 2022. so again
maybe these you know trains maybe these
you know balloons you know it's very
easy to to distract kids with balloons
it's I got three balloons at the top
that's all Brooklyn sees in the house
she loves them the same way you can
distract kids with balloons is the same
way you distract adults with balloons
that could be the case again I am purely
speculating I don't have an Insider
person telling me anything I'm purely
speculating but Pat have you when's the
last time when's the the last time this
much besides 911 all the crazy stuff
that we went through when's the last
time you heard about three trains like
this yeah uh uh UFOs because that's what
the defense secretary Lloyd Lawson said
three identified unidentified flying
objects a Chinese spy balloon that's
just coming over they're shooting down
these things that they won't give us any
explanation of what they are they're not
telling us about this until Americans
were recording it and going yo what what
is that then they have to explain
themselves but we have the highest
defense budget in the world no I was in
the United States Air Force I can tell
you nobody fly nothing is in the air
unless we know that it's in there but
all of a sudden we're letting them come
in the UFOs are happening three trains
are dumping all this stuff the stuff
it's just so much is going on I do want
to know what people like what do you
think what do you think there's anything
that they're trying to distract Us in or
you just think it's just ah this is just
American happens and it's just
happening for regarding this does every
I'm just saying everything this is a
crazy time as much and with the north
stream Pipeline and everything that's
happening I'll address the the Chinese
weather balloon stuff right there I've
watched a lot of content on it and I
think
the pervasive view is that we have a lot
more questions and answers so I think
that we are there's going to be the
Senate Judiciary hearings on whatever's
going to come up the accountability the
we're going to find out what the hell is
going on here uh I don't think this is
going to lead to any sort of hot war
with China I think we can pump the
brakes on that I think there's no uh
debate that China is our uh I'm not I
don't want to use the word enemy
adversary adversary sure so there's
certainly an adversary role but I do
want to focus on the Nordstrom too
because there was two schools of thought
was it Putin why would Putin do this
that you know Putin with his amazing
sense of humor did make a joke about six
months ago when winter was starting yeah
and it was essentially he was telling a
story about a a German boy speaking to
his father about you know why why does
the why do the Russians hate us oh they
don't want us to be warm winter it this
you know this it wasn't a very funny
joke essentially he was basically saying
you know why why do why are we so cold
here in Germany you know because the
world wants us to the world wants the
Russians to suffer and he's like well
are we Russians because we're suffering
is essentially what the premise was so
from from the Putin state of uh state of
mind he's like if we do this we're going
to make
Europe pay by the way Europe has
wholeheartedly embraced the war in
Ukraine every single EU nation is
wholeheartedly on team Ukraine of course
no debate there the entire EU you'll
speak about this probably much more
eloquently than I what I would say is
this
from a non-political standpoint if the
U.S is at war with Russia again
non-politically
wouldn't it kind of make sense to blow
up the Nordstrom to to limit
their ability to pump out oil and and
drive Revenue so whether you like Biden
hate Biden think he's an old senile man
whether he literally it was a gaff and
let one go If This Were conventional
Warfare and we blew up our enemies
pipeline we would all secretly being
like hey good job over here great job
America yeah but in this political
climate we're like what an idiot why
would he uh yeah so I don't necessarily
if we did do it and we sent what do you
call them Frogman okay whatever that is
yeah putting their uh you know yeah
they're in yeah I would say all right
well I guess we're pretty calculated
here in the military uh but you're from
a former USSR czechoslovak well not
exactly
former the Empire
Eastern block correct yes so I'm not I'm
not wrong here what's your take on
what's going on by the way just so we're
clear here do you know the death toll if
you know it just let the audience guess
do you know the death toll of the
current amount of Russians and
ukrainians that have died in the last
year both come on total combined do you
have any idea I have no idea take a wild
guess 5000 500 000 do you know how many
that is in a year to die 500. is that my
right no but just keep in mind in the
entire uh U.S Ward Vietnam I think we
had 50 000 casualties okay six years
whatever friends do you know the number
I have no I just I just ran I thought it
was such how much 200 000 each I thought
200 000 each you Russians have lost 200
000 soldiers and ukrainians almost a
hundred thousand I'm kind of close
according to Norwegian TV and January
22nd General Eric Christopherson
obviously we have big fans of Norway
here we trust their uh research Kai yeah
uh Norwegian Norway's defense has
estimates that over a hundred and eighty
thousand have been killed in Ukraine and
a hundred thousand Ukraine Russians have
you killed in Ukraine I think something
that we're forgetting about because we
were all in the raw raw sister you know
behind Ukraine all right there's a war
this is a year ago support Ukraine what
is actually happening is there a
staggering amount of deaths and just
overall just destruction going on there
there's a full-on war there's a war in
America we're like hey support Ukraine
donate
people are dying oh yeah you
don't think that there's a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand Russian
moms that are crying there what a great
point I don't know that that's nuts
well I suddenly don't think that the
Europeans are acting as though Russia is
a serious threat to the peace and
stability in Europe uh the United States
has been uh heroic in in the amount of
uh Hardware that the United States has
been providing to
um to Ukraine not to mention budgetary
support but it shows you just how weak
the European countries are they've been
relying on the United States for support
for defense since the establishment of
NATO in the 1940s they constantly
refused to meet the meet their targets
in terms of spending on defense and they
have been they've been very cheap when
it comes to supporting uh the ukrainians
they've been relying on the United
States uh the the Brits have done a fair
bit uh the French are dragging their
feet Germans even more so as far as the
Spanish and the Portuguese are concerned
I I don't even know if they are aware
there's a war going on so so I I would
love to see the Europeans actually
stepping up and if they feel that Russia
is really an existential threat to
Europe that they should do their bit
rather than constantly rely on the
United States
clearly it's the countries that Finland
Poland yeah that are surrounding the
polls understand what Russians can do
when they take over your country they've
seen it and and the same with uh with
the Baltic versus the Portuguese and the
the Spanish they're just like Siesta
time and Pat this this goes to me like
with all this stuff and I'm not I'm not
trying to make it political but I mean
we're talking politics with everything
that's going wrong here as we're seeing
it the wars that we're getting involved
with China being able to literally
literally from covid to what they're
doing now do whatever they want and get
away with it I because to me personally
the administration the President Biden
weak as hell I would much rather meet
persons my opinion is my thought I would
much rather go back to two years ago
when the only thing hurting in this
country was people's feelings nothing
country itself I'm being real two years
ago people were like hey he said
something mean none of this would
have been happening during Trump I put I
put my money around my mouth you think a
balloon spying would just be flying over
and all this would be happening
we're trying to it's the same guy that
tried to hold China accountable and just
because he was like oh this is the China
virus you can't you know it's racism
China's doing whatever the hell they
want we owe them all this freaking money
heroin I saw a documentary where a
homeless guy very well spoken and yeah
he was homeless but whatever he's like
look what China's do he was heroin we
don't heroin's gone he goes fentanyl is
the number one thing coming here from
China they're making their money all
right and they're killing Americans so
it's a win-win situation for China who's
holding them accountable all these
hearings all these judicial I'm watching
this right now with Twitter none of
those guys are going to get in trouble
none of them are going to go to jail
they're going to investigate fauci
fauci's Untouchable he'll never mark my
words never none of them will ever see
jail ever period they're gonna go in
front Jim Jordan will yell at him Rand
Paul will yell at him then what it's
gonna happen no I'm being real what
happens Pat there's a total lack of
accountability in DC nobody ever gets 1
000 that's it we didn't start in this
country with an aristocracy but now we
have one in Washington DC it's called
the permanent bureaucracy it doesn't
matter how how much you suck at your job
you get promoted you are basically
unfirable exactly the worst that can
happen to you is that you get reassigned
to a different department you are
pampered you earn a lot of money you can
you barely have to go to work it's a
nice job if you can get it I wish I
could get in I have no desire to get it
okay that's not going to be and Pat take
us out on maybe um
I have nothing to say take us out on a
more opt the future looks brighter even
Elon Musk said it we're trying to have
babies in the last 100 years we've
overcome the Great Depression we've
overcome World War One Two a president
assassination an attempt president
assassination an assassination of MLK
assassination of RFK 911 we've overcome
a lot of things uh is what we've
overcome I think what is awesome about
Seasons like this is seeing leaders
rising up leaders don't wake up during
times of Peace unfortunately leaders
typically are identified and step up
during times of War times of Crisis
times of uncertainty times of fear I
believe the man upstairs is looking down
right now saying okay this is the next
challenge that's being faced let's see
what kind of leaders are going to rise
up and your job and my job is to start
off with our family first
within your household beer leader within
the company that you're working at
choose to be a leader amongst your peers
choose to be a leader amongst your
community your city choose to be amongst
your church if you do go to anything
choose to be a leader if we choose to be
leaders yeah that was having a
conversation with Dylan we're driving a
car now letting them play uh watch the
video of Dana White where he says this
is the season of savages and I had to
watch it and he says if you're a Savage
if you're remotely a Savage you're gonna
can kill everybody in this generation if
you're remotely a Savage him and car
don't have a conversation it's actually
a very good one and a Cardone says I
don't care what people say in every
generation there's a Savage he says yes
and then I look at Dylan and I'm saying
hey what do you what do you think your
Savages is that I'm a Savage assistant
you think you're a Savages I'm a Savage
as well I said you have to be David
blood you don't have a choice you're a
Savage okay and he says but that you
know goes back to the same conversation
yes but Dad you keep saying to David
lassim is a special last name you know
you're just saying that that's not true
I said the only thing that matters is
for us to believe it 100 Nothing Else
Matters it's our job to lead our people
I feel like that about my background I
feel like that about America I feel like
that about Valentine and I feel like
that about capitalism I feel like that
about insurance I feel like that about
anything you represent you ought to have
that kind of respect determination
confidence in so if you to lead
things are going to work out does it
mean we're going to go through someones
I think something weird is going on I
think some weird shit's gonna happen
uh but you know just like you know
history repeats itself leaders are going
to rise up that's what's gonna happen at
the end of the day it's a season we're
having a conversation with a couple guys
in this in the Cigar Lounge one guy says
what topic should be off limits you know
what I told them I said no topic should
be off limits to discuss today at a
dinner or family setting it's our
approach that needs to improve I agree
you can talk any topic let's learn our
approach to make it a little bit more
comfortable for all of us have a
conversation together anyways Marianne
thanks for coming out the link to the
book super abundance is going to be at
the bottom both in the chat and the
description if you haven't ordered it
yet go order it uh super abundance
Marion 2p back at it for the second time
Marion thanks for coming out gang take
care I uh are we doing another podcast
this week rival or no yes Friday with
Jimmy Dore Friday with Jimmy door
perfect we'll see you guys there take
care everybody bye-bye bye-bye thank you